et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés Patricia la manière bonjour
Patricia et Bruno Darou de la rédaction
de France 24 bonjour Bruno bonjour
Raphaël le drapeau ukrainien ne flotte
pas encore sur Kerson mais la Russie la
firme elle a elle a bien entamé son
retrait autour de la seule capitale
régionale que Moscou était parvenu à
conquérir depuis le début de l'invasion
écoutez cet échangir entre le ministre
russe de la Défense Sergueï chevaux et
le chef des opérations militaires russes
en Ukraine Sergueï
camarades ministre de la défense après
une évaluation complète de la situation
actuelle nous suggérons de nous défendre
le long de la rive gauche du fleuve d'y
être
comprenez que ce n'est pas une décision
simple à prendre mais en même temps nous
allons préserver la vie de nos
militaires préparer les forces armées au
combat
restez sur la rive droite du fleuve dans
une zone limitée et sans perspective
grâce à cela une partie de nos soldats
sera libérée et utilisé pour d'autres
activités comme celle de nature
offensive dans d'autres directions en
Ukraine
vladimirovic je suis d'accord avec vos
conclusions et vos suggestions pour nous
la vie des militaires russes c'est
toujours une priorité nous devons
également tenir compte du danger pour la
population civile veillez à ce que tous
les civils préférant partir puissent le
faire
et du côté de qui a fondu c'est
déclarations avec prudence même si l'on
confirme avoir déjà repris une douzaine
de localités dans la journée faut-il
croire Moscou Patricia les
Ukrainiens ont raison de faire profil
bas de toute façon ils ont raison parce
que ce n'est qu'un retrait qui ce qui
est en train de se passer donc comme il
se passe ils vont ils ne vont pas
forcément dire on y va tout de suite je
crois que face à ça on a deux
possibilités soit effectivement les
Russes veulent se retirer et se mettre
faire une ligne à franchissable de
l'autre côté de la rivière et ne plus
bouger et donc ils admettent finalement
qu'ils ont perdu cette ville où c'est
encore une tactique il recule il se
renforce pour mieux réattaquer après
après le gros duo de l'hiver une fois
qu'ils auront reconstitué leur truc donc
il y a deux solutions soit effectivement
un retrait pour peut-être comme dit
certaines négocier enfin bon on est
peut-être pas encore là mais enfin un
véritable retrait une volonté de
conserver et de protéger du crâne ou
d'autres solutions reculées pour mieux
réattaquer après et réattaquer quoi
Carson évidemment avec des missiles en
tout cas si il s'avère incarner créer
une reprend Kerson ce serait une
victoire décisive pour Kiev ou une eau
dans cette guerre oui mais peut-être une
troisième option qu'on a vu dans l'un de
nos reportages aujourd'hui ou des
Ukrainiens autour de Carson et acieve
disait qu'en fait les Russes pouvaient
aussi se retirer de l'autre côté du
fleuve
ne pas réattaquer mais ensuite
littéralement bombardé la ville depuis
mais pas forcément réattaquer à
réinvestir la détruire quoi voilà la
punir la détruire c'est un peu voilà
mais en tout cas faire un nouveau gros
nid voilà c'est ça d'une certaine
manière mais évidemment symboliquement
donc votre question c'était pour Kiev
c'était ce serait une évidemment
décisives dans cette guerre parce que
elle pourrait changer vraiment
durablement pour le coup le cours des
choses elle pourrait changer
effectivement
considérablement le cours de choses
d'abord parce que ça indiquerait que les
Russes sont véritablement ce qu'on dit
déjà depuis plusieurs semaines en réel
l'échange qu'on a vu là était assez bon
ubuesque d'une certaine manière
certainement peut-être mis en scène mais
en tout cas voilà le ministre de la
Défense avait besoin d'entendre un
subordonné quand même lui expliquer
qu'il fallait absolument se retirer
finalement il disait oui bon c'est quand
même lui qui endosse la responsabilité
c'est toujours pas Vladimir Poutine mais
oui ce serait très important parce que
on l'a déjà dit plusieurs fois c'était
la seule que Capital régional qui que
les Russes avaient conquis depuis fin
février c'était un des quatre
territoires qui avait été annexés par
des référendums hautement contestables à
la Russie et effectivement Vladimir
Poutine avait dit que comme c'était
désormais des territoires russes si on
s'attaquait à ces territoires et bien il
y aurait une riposte très très forte
même voilà on sous-entendant que
peut-être il y aura un emploi mais
symboliquement ce serait extrêmement
important
pour l'Ukraine euh d'un point de vue
donc symbolique mais aussi militairement
ça pourrait indiquer un retournement de
l'ensemble de la session on en est pas
là quand même voilà faut quand même
rester prudent effectivement je suis
assez d'accord avec Patricia mais si si
c'était fait il faut vraiment attendre
que que les Ukrainiens 1 est repris
Carson que dans la ville de Carson parce
que c'est aussi une possibilité qui a
été évoquée par certains experts les
Russes n'est pas laissé y compris les
soldats en civil quand une armist retire
elle mine tout hein
mais apparemment il pourrait il pourrait
aussi laisser des soldats russes pour
faire voilà des des combats de rue des
snipers etc donc ça c'est une autre
hypothèse donc faut vraiment attendre
que Carson soit totalement tombé aux
mains voilà l'armement occidentale en
tout cas on peut dire qu'il fait la
différence face à la Russie preuve ça
c'est évident que l'armement occidentale
surtout les missiles qui permettent de
tirer beaucoup plus loin que les
missiles russes c'est à dire que les
Ukrainiens sont dans des positions ou
quand ils tirent ils ne sont pas
ne sont pas touchés par les batteries
missiles mais ce qui est intéressant
aujourd'hui dans ce qui se passe je
trouve c'est que on le voit nous avons
peut-être en parler les déclarations de
Joe Biden des déclarations des
émissaires des militaires américains qui
disent qu'il faudrait peut-être savoir
arrêter cette guerre etc vous savez
on les Américains qu'est-ce qu'ils font
c'est eux qui ont la clé de cette guerre
on l'a on la joue ou on la joue pas en
quelque sorte mais surtout ils savent
que au printemps vers l'été bien leur
stocks vont arriver à être épuisés en
quelque sorte l'Amérique c'est pas un
grand supermarché ou on se fournit comme
ça à un moment donné ils vont avoir des
limites et donc ils préparent je pense
en quelque sorte aussi ce moment où ils
vont vraiment se poser des questions sur
les stocks sur ces fameux armes super
performantes à un moment donné ils ne
pourront plus les livrer on voit ce qui
s'est passé pour les drones ils devaient
pas envoyer des drones qui pouvaient
s'infiltrer très profondément
terriblement ennemi
pendant les voiles en ce moment oui mais
lapin était à dire je refuse les
négociations on le voit bien le
président ukrainien et il a fait toute
une espèce de Chartres où maintenant il
ne dit plus je ne veux plus négocier
avec Poutine
pour la Russie les conditions sont très
difficiles puisqu'effectivement droite
sur les droits de l'homme et cetera mais
il faut savoir que les pays
occidentaux en font autour du G7 c'était
mis d'accord en mars dernier si je ne me
trompe pas où en avril enfin j'ai plus à
date en tête pour dire ça sera les
Ukrainiens qui décideront du temps de
l'arrêt oui mais qui doit effacer les
accords
du temps et après lors de ces
négociations plutôt de l'arrêt de
l'amplitude de de l'accord qui pourrait
revenir donc sur ce qui a été décidé à
Miss c'est à dire des référendums
d'autodétermination les
Ukrainiens disent quand on écoute que
les Ukrainiens disent c'est la
reconquête jusqu'à la Crimée faut bien
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'au
prochain là j'ai qui se qui se réunit
ouvre Vladimir Poutine ne va pas
on pourrait peut-être un peu envisager
une pas une réécriture mais enfin
peut-être on va peut-être négocier les
termes de cette négociation future et la
Russie ou alors effectivement les
Ukrainiens c'est vraiment de la
prospective mais comme ils sont sous
pression des américains ils ont publié
leur condition qui sont littéralement
inacceptables pour Moscou donc ils se
disent bon on fait semblant un peu de
dire qu'on voudrait négocier mais en
fait on veut pas le dégage d'autant plus
que il y a quand même plusieurs signaux
qui montrent que Vladimir Poutine est
assez affaibli lui-même en interne en
externe les Chinois lui ont dit à
nouveau attention à l'arme nucléaire
c'est c'est en gros c'est hors de
question c'est ça que ça voulait dire
même au Kremlin apparemment il est
contesté donc les Ukrainiens se disent
peut-être militairement à l'avantage
politiquement Poutine est affaiblie bon
on va peut-être faire semblant de dire
qu'on pense à négocier mais en fait on
va pas le faire aux États-Unis à présent
à mesure qu'on décortique les résultats
des élections de mi-mandat qui avaient
lieu mardi on s'aperçoit que l'élection
a fait de vainqueurs le républicain Ron
De Santis et dans une moindre mesure Joe
Biden et un perdant Donald Trump
l'ancien président comptait capitaliser
sur la victoire de ses candidats ce
qu'il avait soutenu lors des primaires
républicaines pour lancer sa candidature
à la présidentielle de 2024 pas de
chance pour lui un Bruno c'est candidat
et bien ils ont passé une mauvaise
soirée mardi ouais alors alors pas tous
mais parce que il y en avait je crois
300 sur
587 au total présenté par la République
mais enfin certains de ces babies oui on
passait une mauvaise soirée ont été
battues là j'ai noté me mettre hausse de
multimillionnaire tout Nord Dixon
Herschel Walker car il est qui était
présenté comme une possible
colistière enfin qui n'ont pas encore
gagné du moins ça reste à confirmer
validation et sur la Géorgie il y aura
de toute manière un deuxième un deuxième
tour à cause de voilà des procédures
propres à la Géorgie dit des vins enfin
bon bref d'ailleurs Vans lui pardon il a
gagné mais par contre il a fait plein de
remerciements mais pas être mais pas
trop voilà
en face Joe Biden triomphe pour lui il
est démocrates ont même presque remporté
l'élection écoutez-le
les démocrates ont passé une bonne nuit
nous avons perdu moins de sièges à la
Chambre des Représentants que lors de
n'importe quel élection de mi-mandat
démocrates au cours des 40 dernières
années voilà et puis en portée dans son
enthousiasme Patricia Joe Biden n'a pas
nié son envie de concourir une nouvelle
fois en 2024 est-ce qu'il a raison
d'agiter la perspective d'une nouvelle
candidature et finalement d'interpréter
ces élections comme insatisfait site
personnel en tout cas il a il a une
raison qui n'est peut-être pas sa raison
mais il a une raison c'est de calmer un
peu dans son clan l'émergence de tout un
groupe qui réclame qui veut changer etc
donc il a envie de les calmer en disant
écoutez je suis encore là ne m'enterrez
pas tout de suite et donc il gagne du
temps par rapport à ce qui va se passer
chez les républicains parce que
justement faisant planer la possibilité
qu'il pourrait en évitant que son clan
son camp se dispute et bien il renvoie à
la balle dans les autres en les laissant
se disputer parce que Trump est loin
d'être mort il dispose de 160
député qui sont méga en quelque sorte
mais America great
agains sont
c'est bon si j'ai et donc ces gens-là
vont travailler pour Trump ils ne sont
pas encore prêts à switcher pour notre
ami
écouter dans un instant Bruno néanmoins
ce que disait Patricia c'est oui il veut
effectivement continuer à occuper le
l'espace chez les démocrates mais non
mais faut dire aussi que ces fautes de
combattants parce qu'on ne voit pas de
nouvelles figures émergées on a évoqué
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est confirmée
des espoirs placés en elle non pour le
moment c'est un peu le problème chez
démocratie il y a un manque de voilà de
de renouvellement de leadership donc
évidemment jobiden effectivement Kabala
Harris en gros la mayonnaise a pas pris
alors est-ce que c'est dû à la fonction
de de vice-présidente qui fait que le
vice-président le vice-président est
toujours un peu dans l'ombre du
président où est-ce que tout simplement
la passion imprime à sa marque toujours
est-il que c'est un vrai problème et que
c'est évidemment un avantage pour Joe
Biden effectivement comme disait patr en
tout cas il a dit parce que précisément
il a dit j'ai toujours l'intention de me
représenter je vous donnerai ma réponse
au début de l'année prochaine
et pendant ce temps effectivement il va
avoir comment ça se passe côté
républicain parce que normalement Donald
Trump devrait faire sa déclaration la
semaine prochaine le 14 juillet 15 mars
voilà le 15 il va peut-être sans doute
annoncé qu'il se représente alors
effectivement il a passé une mauvaise
nuit quand même comparé à ce qu'il
attendait mais on fait une reste très
puissant il a effectivement le rhum des
saintes qui qui lui était très très bien
élu gouverneur qui a 44 ans et en fait
ce qui est un peu compliqué pour lui
c'est que finalement Rome de sortie s'il
est quasiment sur la même ligne
idéologique que lui le complotisme en
moins parce que ce serait plus simple si
c'était un candidat républicain
mainstream pourra dire voyez nos
différences etc là ça va être quand même
plus compliqué il a commencé à
l'attaquer plus extrémiste sur des
certaines positions
que que Donald Trump
ultra conservateur donc voilà Donald
Trump il commence à l'appeler Rona
morale etc enfin c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment des arguments et puis
il y en a qu'il faut pas oublier c'est
leur service président Mike pence qui
apparemment bon souviens de la manière
dont il a été pour avoir refusé
d'invalider l'élection de Joe Biden
lui apparemment aussi il a ton devoir et
il reste en embuscade le grand vainqueur
en tout cas pour l'instant c'est lui un
round De Santis a réussi à faire
souffler une vague rouge sur la Floride
écouter le à l'heure de commenter son
succès
il y a encore tant à faire durant les
quatre prochaines années et pour ma part
je ne fais que commencer le combat
voilà et puis c'est parti en eux
l'incitait à aucune
alors qu'il a été élu évidemment pour 6
ans manières de dire et bien dans 2 ans
il faut passer un autre bureau le bureau
valent en l'occurrence un candidat
sérieux Patricia ah oui je crois un
candidat sérieux alors il est pas
mainstream pour le coup en terme d'idées
à la droite du parti républicain qui a
des idées très ancrées mais qui
a su convainc complètement l'électorat
et en particulier les hispanos
qui ont voté
en majorité pour lui ce qui était qui
n'existait pas avant et il a pour lui la
façon dont il a traité le covid en
rouvront tout on ouvrant les écoles il a
pour lui aussi le fait d'avoir une
politique en matière fiscale très
attirante donc on va vers cette terre de
liberté qui en revanche sur les
questions sociales il est complètement
presque à la droite de Trump j'ai envie
de dire il a des positions très dures
sous toutes les questions des
homosexualités là
donc est-ce qu'il sera rassemblé toute
l'Amérique ça c'est pas évident du tout
une Amérique qui est très pour l'instant
divisée mais on a l'impression qu'on va
pas échapper à cette Amérique divisée
il est moins complotiste que Trump mais
il est moins il est moins farfelu et
aussi donc il est moins charismatique
quand même donc comment ça va comment ça
va se jouer mais c'est sûr qu'il y aura
une forme de d'affrontement entre les
deux en tout cas il a réussi et lui avec
un seul point d'avance il y a 6 ans et
bien il a réussi à être élu avec cette
fois 20 points d'écart avec son
adversaire c'est-à-dire effectivement la
percée effectuée en 6 ans par Rome de
scène 6 auprès des Floridiens merci
Patricia lemonnière merci Bruno Darou
c'était ton va plus loin on se retrouve
dans 4 minutes pour un nouveau journal
dans Paris direct
[Musique]